luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys welcome back to the lehigh
show powered by icon plus capital the vc firm
and sponsored by blockfi and luno so today i have
a very interesting guest to give us a whole new
perspective a topic which i've actually not
spoken about before but before we do um as
usual i do want to let you know that at the
moment i'm giving a really special offer on
my paperback book undressing bitcoin everybody
who has the paperback i'm actually giving away
a free version of the audio before the audio goes
live next week so of course it's just limited time
before the audio goes live i'm giving everyone who
has the paperback free access to the audiobook so
definitely check that out i think i've left
it somewhere on my twitter profile so you can
check that out so joining me today is writer
and journalist it is lee quinn lee how are you
hey everybody i'm doing pretty good thanks for
having me yeah i'm so excited to chat to you we've
spoken a little bit we've come across each other a
little bit but i don't know a lot about you i know
you're a writer i know you're a journalist i've
seen a lot of your work but i'd love to learn more
about you before crypto what's your background
and where are you from yeah life before crypto
yeah um so i'm originally from california i've
been a journalist for roughly a decade so i've
worked with organizations like tech crunch the
jerusalem post la times yada yada i've been
doing this for a while previously i was covering
politics in the middle east i lived in israel for
almost five years doing that then i moved to new
york and i was off a job as a sex writer i worked
for mike and also a variety of publications
like salon different things teen vogue
um covering things related to gender issues and i
switched into crypto in 2017 completely by chance
i was interviewing with newsweek media group and
originally interviewing for a job in fashion tech
and they were like actually we need someone to
cover this whole blockchain thing do you think
can handle it and i can't believe i literally
said i was like it's like a chain of blocks
right i'm sure i can figure this out um i briefly
heard about bitcoin back when i was in israel uh
in relation to dark net markets and um some of
the things i was uh reporting on really to sex
trafficking and and sexual abuse uh and so
when i was exposed i guess to this different
side this more social side uh this side that
has so much potential in terms of doing good
for the world i was really fascinated and uh
it's been four years so been there ever since
so you have done so much you mentioned reporting
in israel you mentioned sex trafficking um just a
whole load of very different things what would you
say the most interesting or even like the weirdest
thing you've done in your journalism career
because it can get weird oh yeah it can get super
weird um wow that's a really good question i don't
know what the weirdest thing is i've ever done
porn conferences are really fun and quirky and
weird but honestly crypto conferences are equally
weird and quirky um did you say porn conferences
what's up yeah and conference exactly like your
crypto conference there'll be conferences in
which um adult performers and people who work in
the industry get together they talk about you know
new uh payment tools they talk about broadcasting
tools they talk about you know compliance issues
all the things that are relevant to their industry
that is so fascinating in terms of this industry
because i know you talk about it a lot i'd love
to learn a little bit more about it you say that
they are a very um let's just say they're sort
of at the forefront when it comes to crypto
adoption because there's a lot of issues that
they face explain that to me yeah definitely so
i'll have to confess that actually my family is
pretty religious and conservative i came into
journalism with a very conservative perspective
and i was actually if you would probably ask me
when i was like 22 or something i would have said
porn is like bad for women and you know always
exploitive and it was only through reporting on
this industry that i changed my opinion there are
a lot of people who are actively choosing this who
have advanced degrees or have a lot of other
opportunities and they're doing it because
it's frankly the way they have the most
freedom and the most fun in their work
and there's a lot of ways especially these days
when people can broadcast from home they can
choose who they record with what they record how
they project themselves as opposed to being like
basically an entertainer who is controlled by
a studio um there's a lot of freedom that these
people have a lot of them uh so certainly not
everyone but society is still i mean honestly
the worst thing about being an adult entertainer
is the way that banks and other institutions treat
you good luck taking anyone to court if they treat
you wrong the court will probably not side in
your favor and in fact there are some people who
might lose custody of their kids really for doing
nothing wrong um but just because there's a stigma
so it's like what would a bank do that is wrong
so a bank can shut down their account considering
it's a reputational risk even if what they're
doing is perfectly legal um it's the porn industry
is perfectly legal industry in california and
nevada and a lot of places in the um but it can
it's considered a reputational risk the same way
that guns or marijuana are so they can lose access
to all their funds they can lose all their funds
they can get blacklisted and that applies not only
to your bank account but that applies to like your
paypal your cash up your facebook like literally
anything that can connect your government id you
can get banned from all of those things at once
even sometimes developer sites like braintree
will ban a sexual sex worker so it was really
crazy to me to watch that there are women who are
choosing this line of work doing it safely and
lawfully they pay taxes um and still being treated
like criminals um and really almost hunted by
the government like anywhere they are online
being kicked off being restricted um and i mean
in addition to that they have to deal with guys
who you know might be a stalker or weird so like
there's this dual um uh safety risk that they have
so because of that um i mean honestly most of the
sex workers i talk to are so much better at using
cyberpunk tools than i ever will be because they
have to protect themselves and their family what
fascinated me from from that the most was was
i guess your change yeah you said you come from
a very conservative background initially
you know you thought porn was bad or evil
what was it that really changed your mind because
i have a different opinion on porn to you but
that doesn't really matter but i'm interested
to know what changed your mind i guess just
meeting a lot of the people who are choosing
to do it and seeing that they are i've like
as a journalist there's a lot of times that that
job can feel really exploitive you know you can
be forced to write things that you don't believe
in um or you'll lose your job you can be forced to
um interview people that you feel like don't
deserve the attention or frankly will be harmed
by the attention um and a lot of sex workers i
talk to are exploited less in their jobs than the
journalists i know um they choose who they sell
to what they sell how often they do it what their
price is and all these different kinds of choices
that go into making a work environment that seems
really safe and empowering for them that's not
everybody there are certainly people like all
jobs right like not everyone who's a janitor feels
empowered about being a janitor but the idea that
like i met so many mothers and even grandmothers
frankly and just people who i didn't think of as
like young and impressionable who are like making
these active choices and gaining economic freedom
through that that it just changed my mind in
terms of like people should have the right to
make those choices with their bodies if they want
to and the idea that like no one is stopping nicki
minaj from making a music video that is basically
pornographic um but so like if you are owned
by a studio if you have like handlers corporate
handlers it's perfectly fine for you to sell this
content but if you are an independent woman who's
choosing to do it yourself and get all the profits
you'll face all these banking restrictions
that feels to me like an archaic uh overhang
of the idea that women don't own their own bodies
and don't have the right to make those choices i
think it's an interesting comparison because porn
doesn't necessarily mean hard porn it can be soft
and i would certainly agree that nicki minaj and
to be honest the rest of that kind of industry is
absolutely soft porn um 100 i'm with you um but
just in terms of crypto then how did you actually
stumble across that yeah so uh when i was working
for so first when i was working in israel uh yeah
some people were using this weird bitcoin thing
on darknet markets and so i just heard about that
very briefly then when i was in new york and i was
working for a music media group they assigned me
to this beat and so it was my job to write about
it all day every day and i was very lucky that i
already had these contacts from the porn industry
because a lot of those women will save for their
retirement or for their kids college funds for
example in bitcoin because the bank you can't
get cut off you know you just hold it yourself um
and so from that combination of things my work is
signing it to me and having all these contacts
who had this experience that they could share
with me i was really lucky that i was able to
really dive um head first into the industry
so are you bitcoin only you know it's it's
such a hot topic or do you look at the the
cryptocurrency industry as a whole you look at the
ecosystem you look at d5 and just like you know
this is the future everything will be built on
all of this whether it's bitcoin or something else
i'm a money maximalist i like money um so
hmm i'm not against other cryptocurrencies
at all as they exist and frankly i've used
them i've sold nfts with my poems inside
and i can always use eth to buy bitcoin if that's
what i want i don't see it as wrong or weird
to use other kinds of money if that's what people
want to use when i'm in israel i use shekels when
i'm transacting with the ethereum community they
want to transact with me in ether stable coins and
that just opens me up to more clients
and more people i can collaborate with
um even if all i want to hold myself is bitcoin
but from like a philosophical standpoint right
because it is quite an emotional topic it just is
it gets very philosophical and emotional you know
how do you feel are you bitcoin only you know
or are you just using and using the other coins
just for the sake of people wanting to buy and
buy and sell with you in those um assets i don't
feel emotionally attached to the dollar although
i use it a lot i don't feel emotionally attached
to um eath or to die or to any of the
other currencies that i've used it's just
like the dollar it's it's just a a means to an end
it's a means to transact um and to gain value um
i don't feel philosophically that it's wrong to
do those things i do feel pretty strongly about
selling it to people especially people who might
not be educated or have access to other kinds
of resources i think we should be very very
uh selective and careful about the way that
we talk about cryptocurrency but i don't think
there's anything morally wrong with using it no
i'm totally with you i think it's unfortunate that
there's so much um tribalism in the space i think
everything offers interesting value and it'd be
impossible to predict in 10 years and 20 years
what the market demands and what can be built oh
yeah i think i think it's an interesting space and
i'm so excited to see what else happens but in
terms of your career why did you decide to then
stay in crypto you must have had a moment where
you were just like yeah this makes sense this is
the future um i'm just really lucky so because i
had this long history of journalism and different
kinds of topics you know politics culture um
before i came to crypto i i understood how hard
it is to make a difference um maybe i wrote an
article that was read by like six million people
but most of them forgot it within 10 minutes
of reading it you know or something like that
i also did um some of the election
politics around uh trump's first election
yeah exactly it was pretty awful um and
although reporting in the bitcoin space
can be very difficult and very exhausting you make
a huge difference with your readers i mean i get
letters all the time from people telling me like
oh i'm finally getting my first hardware wallet
because i read your thing and i feel like it's
not too scary for me thank you so much or oh i
didn't even know that this was possible for me to
use it this way or um oh i gave this to my cousin
and like she was in an abusive relationship
and now she's saving bitcoin herself to like
get a lawyer and get out or whatever these things
are like you have this like really direct relation
relationship with your readership and that's
so rewarding that like i can't imagine wanting
to cover anything else that makes so much sense i
feel the same i feel like everything matters more
everything means more you know whatever it is
whether you're even on a podcast like this this
conversation has more impact than the traditional
world because you're right it's so saturated
the connection has been very much disjointed
between you and your reader or you and your
listeners whatever it is um but in terms of
reporting on it how how do you say reporting on
crypto is different to reporting on traditional
news you said you know trump's election and
what was it oh my gosh 15 or something 16.
yeah something like that i think was 15. um
wow it's it's so so so different um it's like
it combines all of these different things
i would say that the thing that it's most similar
to reporting on that i have experience with
is the israeli-palestinian conflict and i say that
because it's extremely polarizing everyone's going
to be upset with you no matter what you say but
it's very very hard to get to um an objective view
of facts you know one side will say one thing
one side will say a totally different thing
um and unlike the israeli palestinian conflict
where like maybe you might go to like amnesty
international or the u.n to look at um uh data
that is supposed to be less bias supposed to be
yeah exactly supposed to be not really but like at
least there's at least we know who those players
are right the crypto space is so new that like
you have no idea what are people's motives where
this data is coming from like you would really
have to be a very uh sophisticated engineer
to fact check a lot of these articles and nobody
in journalism actually has time for like to spend
literally 24 hours fact checking your thing making
sure that code is clean making sure that people
actually own what they say they own um so you
have to figure out how to fact check in a very
different way and to always have this mentality
of understanding like things will change you could
come up with better data you know like 10 minutes
after the article is published and want to update
in traditional journalism updates are really bad
like you'll get criticized from your editors about
it even if the data wasn't available before
and you just want to make it a better article
uh there's this feeling that like an update means
that you did something wrong and so they don't
want to do it um i think with a crypto mentality
you have to take this approach of like um
releasing it to the wild becomes this live thing
and you do the best you can to keep continually
updating it with the best data that you can in
the circumstance you have that's just a totally
different approach to fact checking into reporting
i feel like that was when i was writing my book
everything was changing and i was like gosh
guys can the community just stop for a second
i'm trying to get something out yeah it's so fast
oh my god it's so fast it is so fast and i think
it's really interesting that you know you compared
it to the uh palestinian israeli conflict because
that that resonates you know there's never that
um that objective truth unfortunately things are
moving changing everything's a reaction of
a reaction um but fact checking is a really
i'm glad you you pulled that up because we
had the reuters uh headline um about litecoin
so that was interesting because you can tell me
you know reuters they that would they just copy
headlines of other news headlines about the news
headlines they came through on the wire apparently
and you know they just sort of oh if bbc for
example are printing it then it must be correct
what was your take on that why did they
mess that up so much they're supposed to be
the reputable ones we're the ones that need to
do the update right i have so much sympathy for
that stuff um it's it's not unique to reuters
everyone in the mainstream media business these
days is aggregating um and when you're when you're
like the lowest level journalist on the team like
for example i've interviewed with some of the
i mean really top names that you would consider
like okay these are the people that we always
trust they're super great and uh when i would
interview with them they'd be like we need you to
write 10 uh 10 articles a day and okay if you're
doing 10 on goals today and a 10 hour work
day and you know let's say it's crazy yeah
30 to 40 minutes of that is actually getting up
on the website loading into cms putting a photo
putting tag words you know emailing your boss
until it's up whatever all that administration
you're telling me what you want me to do is write
an article in 20 minutes that's not something i
could feasibly fact check like in any stretch of
the imagination um so like just the expectations
that are put on these little reporters are so
so high and if you don't meet them they'll just
fire you and find someone else who's eager to do
your job so i have so much sympathy for people who
uh fall for uh these pranks uh on like why are
press releases that are not true um because
they're just given an impossible situation i think
that's why it's really important for people to
find media that they trust and the best they can
um and then pay for it because there's really
no way that when you're consuming a free product
that that product is going to be made to serve you
it's just not what is your overall opinion
on the mainstream media as somebody who has
been in crypto for four years now um you know
obviously you have that traditional background but
it is for example we had the headline i think it
was cnbc oh there's so much to talk about my gosh
okay inflation for example the whole trying
to make inflation sound pretty um you know
uh just because inflation is rising
that means higher salaries well
that's misinformation number one number two um the
way they're talking about el salvador is really
interesting um you know they said that el salvador
adopting bitcoin would would mean i think it's
western union would lose around 400 million a year
um but actually that means you're saving exactly
as opposed to you know helping an improvisation
save 400 million a year so what's your take
i think those headlines do their job
and if their job is to make people click
then they're effective yeah right but that's
exactly you start to realize the incentive model
is against you as a reader as opposed to for you
and try and find new sources that uh the essential
model is to serve you um because otherwise i mean
like nobody is shocked when you go into a casino
and you lose the house the house always wins
that's kind of what mainstream media has become
doesn't okay but we know that that's a gambling
house mainstream media holds itself supposedly
to this beautiful incredible standard and we are
god's truth you know we are especially the bbc in
the uk it's quite it's quite insufferable if i'm
honest um you know and yeah they hold themselves
to this this truth like they're doing god's work
did it was there something in that that put you
off working in that kind of industry yeah totally
i mean and to be fair i still do uh sometimes
pitch and work with um mainstream outlets but yeah
when i thought about wanting to progress my career
one of the reasons that i'm working independently
now and not focusing on trying to get a staff job
somewhere like that is because it's so annoying
and infuriating even this whole um i have the
right opinion for a reason uh for a reason like
i get paid to be so righteous kind of attitude
you have to remember that a lot of people
got into this industry because they want to
make a difference in the world um they they
came in with these big idealistic visions
and then they are confronted with this capitalist
monstrosity that just twists their ability to do
anything good um and so a lot of people still you
can do good with an article though to be fair um
i'll give an example of like i wrote one article
um about an educational program in afghanistan it
was a zillion years ago that was being defunded
um and suddenly after my article was published
they found the funding to keep the school
open like media can make a huge difference
um but just the question of whether
that's what you actually do day to day
is it's very rare and people don't really have
that uh that connect between the actual impact
they're having on the world day-to-day versus what
their intentions were when they came in and tried
and do you think we're gonna get denise is gonna
get worse i mean at the end of the day the whole
idea behind journalism was that it was the
mediator to tell you the truth you know someone
a source that you can rely on that's certainly
how like you said the bbc and reuters present
themselves and the rest of american news outlets
they really present themselves as like you know
doing god's work that's really dangerous because
there are still people that believe that so do you
think we're going to get to a point where people
number one wake up and realize that actually these
people their job is to have headlines yeah make
crazy headlines and get the clicks and number two
do you think we'll get to a place where we can
actually have some um objective journalism so
there is objective journalism that exists
right um there are some images unbiased
i mean what is bias every human being has bias
right i think the best way to be unbiased is
to acknowledge what your biases are so that people
can come in and read it without uh with that frame
um and there is some amazing journalism that still
exists i mean there are some great non-profits
there are some good um and like i want to actually
maybe push back against that idea that the
original idea of journalism was to have an
objective truth at least in the united states
when we think of the colonial newspaper history
i mean like ben franklin was running a newspaper
like they were actually for political parties
they were a way to get messages out promoted
by a particular group and then like as we see the
evolution of journalism you see okay well how do
you convince people to buy more of your paper then
you market it not as the republican paper or the
democrat paper you mark it as the truth paper and
that should hopefully bring more people in across
party lines like there's there was not like an
original concept of like the journalism wasn't
about making the bible it was about talking to
people before the internet or phones existed
and the best way to get information from point
a to point b was to print it and send it out
so i think that we're seeing something
that's moving back along those lines of
understanding that journalism has an agenda like
somebody took the time to write this up print
this up and get it in front of your eyeballs that
was expensive what do they want out of you when
they took all this time and money to do that
right and so i hope that us as consumers can
promote for young people and also amongst
ourselves media literacy so that we can
identify those motivations from the media because
then there could be like great information in the
thing um but it's framed in such a way to make
me feel a certain way but if i come into it
being like oh they're trying to piss me off okay
let's take that aside is that true is this true
and then i can use that information to benefit
myself i'm an adult i can make those choices
um the problem is when we don't realize that
we're being manipulated so just uh i think
improving education on media literacy and
like the understanding of how that industry
works is the only way to kind of counteract uh
that mass scale manipulation that is happening
would you agree that there seems to be um a
narrative across all media right now that you know
inflation isn't as bad as it as we as we think
and crypto is bad would you agree that there
seems to be that narrative yeah that that seems
to be a popular opinion a very popular opinion
okay so why do you think that's the case
why do you think there's this anti-crypto
narrative in across the media globally i think i
think it has a lot more to do with the reputation
of the loudest bitcoiners than it has to do
with the technology itself like when they
hear bitcoin all they do is associate it with
like some angry trump supporting troll who like
is going to like post stakes everywhere and is all
about guns and actually there's nothing wrong with
supporting trump or liking stakes or guns um but
this uh association of the asset with this like
caricature and yeah often that caricature being
like the loudest meanest person on the internet
makes people feel like it's this like um it makes
them think something that is actually not true at
all to the original technology like we're all
wearing pants in a shirt that doesn't mean that
people who wear pants and shirts do x y z thing um
i think as people are exposed to a wider variety
of people who use these tools and for a wider
variety of reasons um that that stigma will lessen
but at the moment you're correct that stigma is
extremely intense and like literally anytime i
say bitcoin people assume that means that i'm like
um want to like take down the government and that
i want to like yell at them about running a server
in their house and like maybe grandma doesn't need
to run a server in her house or doesn't know how
and i'm not going to judge her for that you know
yeah but what about inflation because inflation's
clearly a problem and you know you had the fed
coming out with oh it's transitory or maybe it's
not actually transitory um and perhaps inflation
is good you know all these rubbish headlines which
i think have been um recycled in the media why
would they do that when we know that this is not a
good idea we're already seeing prices increase um
across the world i mean in the uk inflation right
now is pretty bad so it's not an honest message
isn't it more comforting to think that you
can print more money and then that's good
than the idea that there are finite resources and
we need to figure out how to deal with what we
already have like i feel like that's a much more
comforting message if i was going to try and sell
something to someone who doesn't understand what
the words mean i would definitely try and sell
them something that's sweeter and goes down easier
it makes you just it makes you really just want to
give up on on the media and people have you know
yeah i actually really support it um i think some
of this uh the best advice i've ever gotten was to
only consume media deliberately and purposely like
if i'm trying to figure out what happened in xyz
place because i have a cousin there and i want to
like text her or something and i want to know if
her internet's down because there's a hurricane
or like you know whatever it is that i'm looking
for a specific piece of information i look for it
and literally anything else it's not made to serve
me so i'm not going to consume it um there might
be um writers that i really like and so i'll like
if they you know write a thing and i'll be like
okay maybe i'll read that even though it's not
something i'm deliberately seeking out just for
entertainment but i think that people should be
much more selective about how they spend their
their reading time their viewing time and to
know that everything you put in your brain
has an impact in some way so you have to be
really protective of yourself and that's such
a great way to put it actually um i made a tweet
the other day sort of saying how oh my gosh i
turned on the radio for a few minutes and it felt
like doomsday turned it off but you're out and
then everybody was like oh you need to know what's
going on in the world but you're right the only
thing i want to know is if i need a covert test to
fly if i need to be vaccinated to fly that's all i
want to know so you're right when i want to know
that i will intentionally go and search for it
and get the information you do have to
be deliberate it's a great way to put it
um in terms of bitcoin then what would you say
some of the biggest challenges are when reporting
on it i know you spoke about fact checking but
is there anything else which which you find to
be um quite a hurdle that you wouldn't really
have with traditional news yeah there's just not
a lot of great experts to interview about bitcoin
there are a lot of people who have opinions about
bitcoin there's not a lot of people who actually
know what they're talking about um and it can be
very difficult to get interviews with them because
they are extremely understandably suspicious of
the media uh so even when you are a reporter who
is genuinely trying to do the right thing you know
let's say you're on deadline you've got two hours
you're gonna write this article about bitcoin you
call up you know 20 people who are really involved
in this space who really understand the technology
what are the chances that even four of them
will answer you because they're just been so
conditioned that the media is out to get them so
um getting really good interviews and sources is
a problem fact checking is huge and difficult
and also um dealing with the the bureaucratic
castle that any publication has so you don't only
have to convince like you know your reader that
for example bitcoin mining is not going to boil
the oceans you have to convince your editor who
has a very strong opinion about it and has the
ability to change your article uh with your name
on it right so you have to convince him and then
you have to convince his editor above him and you
have to like really internally fight this battle
in order to for research they haven't done for
things they don't understand they think that they
understand bitcoin and they don't so it's both
like the difficulty of getting the information
in a timely fashion and then convincing the
publication and all the people involved that
you did get the right information that you
know what you're talking about even if what what
i'm saying is contradictory to what they believe
oh my gosh i can really relate to that i did an
article recently um for um a women's magazine
about bitcoin i was the bitcoin expert which was
all very exciting um but basically they at the two
things went wrong and i was very annoyed um the
editors at the top changed it and before it went
live i was like no no you got to keep it as i did
it otherwise i don't want this going out so two
things first thing was right at the bottom they
asked me do you think it's a male dominated space
now my response was it is male dominated but
i don't think that's a problem x y and z like
it is obviously if you look at the stats but i
don't think it's a problem because blah blah blah
but they they they twisted it and they changed
it to leia said this is a male dominated space
very subtle but it changes the tone and
the entire message and that's just not
something that i would freely bring up because
it's not something i particularly care about
um and then it portrays me in a whole new light
and i was very disappointed we got it fixed
very good but i was annoyed yeah and then the
second thing which is also really interesting
is you know you have because we're the so-called
bitcoin expert you have big big b and little b
yeah and they'd messed it up in the article and i
was like no you really need to correct it because
it looks like i've messed up because it's my
words and they wouldn't correct it and like
they wouldn't take the time to understand
why it was wrong and why it looks bad um
we put it out in the end but like you know it
it's just frustrating you're right you have to get
everybody on board and you have to prove that
you know what you're talking about even though
it may not make sense to them and you mentioned
uh sometimes you can't get the changes that you
want so that's very true and i can't even count
the amount of times that i've been uh trolled
or people wrote me hate mail for changes that i
actually crusaded against behind the scenes but i
can't i couldn't get i lost those you win some
you lose some um and people have a really hard
time understanding because yours is the only name
on that article so not only uh do you have this a
real challenge in terms of getting things right
um but any little thing you mess up the bitcoin
community is extremely reactive crypto community
in general beyond bitcoin extremely reactive
extremely vocal and you're just going to take heat
for every single thing and so i totally get why a
lot of reporters are just like i don't think
it's worth that like it's it's exhausting and
it's frustrating and i would rather avoid it than
make a mistake in public i totally understand why
some people have that approach um but i think and
i hope that you know some people like you and me
are willing to make those mistakes in public or
willing to fight those battles um and that we're
still able to get out high quality information to
the mass audience right because like bitcoiners
can talk to bitcoiners they'll write these you
know 20 page uh creeds about why it's so amazing
to have hard money and that's great but that's
never going to reach a different kind of reader
that wasn't already looking for that so it's
really important to have a wide variety of people
writing a wide variety of stories um and making
a wide variety of content about bitcoin that is
all accurate on that note though um you
know talking about reporting on bitcoin
in a traditional standpoint what fascinates me um
and i didn't know this until laura shin had spoken
about it you probably know what i'm about to say
is the idea that you can't hold bitcoin if you're
gonna report on bitcoin so my first question
to you is do you you hold crypto right despite
reporting on it very very small amounts i honestly
liquidate more than i that i hold but uh yeah
both i guess i mean part of it is just at this
point like a lot of my income is related to
the industry and so if i want to pay rent
that's usually uh in some ways related to
the income that i have accessible um and
part of it is yeah i'm not wanting to hold
i'm also a public figure right this is my
name in my face right here broadcasting
talking about bitcoin um so we're very
vulnerable to wrench attacks i think it
would be very dumb for someone who is publicly
putting their name and face to bitcoin to hold
an excessive amount and be public about the
fact that they're holding excessive amount
so i try and liquidate um whenever i can uh
but that being said i do hold some it's really
necessary for me to do things right like i was
just uh this week trying a lightning node thing
and if i didn't already have bitcoin it would have
taken me forever to buy it and transfer it and
blah because i already had a lightning wallet like
i could start setting up and testing this tool
um it is true that i've had editors tell me
that this makes me biased and that means that my
opinion cannot be trusted um i also hold dollars
and i don't see anyone complaining about that so
i feel i feel like it is true like if if like
90 of your wealth is in bitcoin um it's going to
influence your opinion but if 90 of your wealth
is in dollars that's gonna probably influence your
opinion too and i don't see a huge distinction
although not all editors feel that way and i think
laura is very smart that she has decided that for
her career it is more beneficial to her to work
with some of those editors who have that opinion
than it is to hold and that's that's a choice
but laura must obviously be very interested
in crypto she must really like it to want to
cover it so much so oh my god missing out on
that kind of opportunity just blows my mind
it's a trade-off right like you know that you're
never going to be able to work with such and such
editor and such and such publication if if you
hold um so i personally have not made that choice
and i'm okay with giving up that opportunity cost
to have like an amazing byline in this very famous
paper um but other people uh feel differently
and i think that's that's a personal choice
yeah it really it really fascinates me because
mainly because of what you brought up you know
you hold dollars you hold pounds 90 or maybe even
100 of an individual's wealth is in fiat currency
and you can still report on that it sort
of reminds me actually um of donald trump
because i keep having this conversation people
keep saying trump is anti-bitcoin and i don't
necessarily think he is i just think he's a fiat
or he's a us dollar maximalist who understands you
know the threat that bitcoin has to the us dollar
therefore doesn't want any you know it doesn't
want any bitcoin so in some ways that's like a
you know a bias policy when i mean he's obviously
not president everyone has bias there is no such
thing as unbiased there is only identifying your
own bias which is the only way forward which
which is really interesting in terms of your
general perspective about bitcoin um do you see
it then as this store of value do you see as this
asset which is helping um either impoverish
people people from different difficult um
industries like sex workers and stuff like what is
your um general perspective on bitcoin's use case
so at the moment it's digital money and just like
other kinds of digital money some people that use
it are just gambling and some people that use it
use it because they really need it they don't have
access to those local tools otherwise i definitely
do know of people who um all around the world not
even just sex workers you know whether you're
talking about venezuela whether you're talking
about iran whether you're talking about south
africa um people that are using bitcoin for
really wholesome and like you know pg
reasons totally pg family friendly reasons
and i think that's great i've heard some really
inspiring stories of people who were able to make
empowering life choices because they had this
access to a tool that gave them financial freedom
i'm sure if someone had dropped a million dollars
on their doorstep it would have had a similar
financial effect right like they have the freedom
of choice at that point um but the only way they
got that freedom of choice was through bitcoin
and that's great i think it's very very silly
when people refer to this asset as if that's
the only way people use it because that's not
the only way people use it and that's okay it's
money people do all kinds of things with money
um and i'm not trying to moralize it and say that
it's bet like i'm morally superior for having
this kind of money versus other people who have
different kinds of money i think that it's pretty
evident that it's a good way to save and transact
uh for a few years in the future at least it's
been around for 10 years and it seems to be very
consistent in terms of its history and pattern
i have no idea what the world is going to look
like in a hundred years because if you'd asked
someone 100 years ago what the world would
look like today they never could have predicted
facebook they never could have predicted a lot
of the things that impact our world today so
i can't predict what bitcoin will be worth in a
hundred years i can say that for the near future
that i can see it seems to still be a pretty good
tool uh for saving and transacting particularly
for people who don't have access to the kinds
of banking services that a millionaire might
yeah for me it's really that end point which i'm
just in love with the way bitcoin is completely
revolutionizing um africa jumping to the fourth
industrial revolution of you know smart technology
and all of that but in terms of we mentioned
that 10-year gap like we said we've spoken
about there's a lot of hostility whether it's
from the government and the infrastructure bill
which was ridiculous um you know
whether it's the mainstream media
do you think we'll get to a point where eventually
um let's call it the system we'll turn around and
have a change of opinion um or do you think
we're gonna have to continue fighting this
i don't have a lot of optimistic opinions there
actually yeah i think the us government has not
proven to be kind in its uh imperialist motives
and losing the dollars supremacy globally would
not be something that would make a lot of people
in the government happy so i think so what we've
seen so far with bitcoin's adoption right is
like when we have countries where it becomes more
popular um than the local fiat or not even more
than the local fiat but like even a mild threat
uh we think of the examples like venezuela
or iran the government's clamp down on that
hard and do all kinds of weird things that are
not necessarily good for the industry that doesn't
end bitcoin it's not the end of bitcoin it is just
more difficult for people to safely use it who
aren't like crazily smart engineers who can build
their own computer and use a ham radio and do
all these things to protect their privacy um i
don't think the future of bitcoin in the us is
a smooth ride i don't think they're just like
oh well actually this is good for everyone so
we're just going to allow it um and because
that's not the case in the us is currently the
dominant world economy second only to china or
maybe even on par with china that's going to be
bad for a lot of people um and i mean we've seen
how china is reacting to the crypto market right
um i think that we're going to see a lot more
of that what will happen in the future beyond
that could be very positive right like if you
had asked someone during the french revolution
like what will happen to like the concept of
democracy there was like a lot of bloodshed
and a lot of hardship before things got better
so i feel like we're in this the very beginning
now of something that's going to get worse before
it gets better um but that being said that means
it's this incredible opportunity to play like this
unique role in history where you can help people
gain access to tools that they had no idea existed
and opportunities that they never would have had
before and how many people in their lives can say
that they have that opportunity to impact so many
other people's lives in a positive way so i'm
not like down about the fact that we're in that
place in history i'm excited about the fact that
i get to play a role that actually helps people
i think that speaks true for a lot of society
right now um it kind of is true for the for
the grand scheme of things you know like i'm
a freedom maximalist so we've seen a huge um
clamp down on freedom and human restrictions and
i do think that we're about to go down a dark
path and i don't necessarily mean that in a dark
way because i always think that there are ways
around everything and i think that everything
will be fine as long as you associate yourself
with like-minded people and you know you're smart
and you know what you're doing i think it's fine
um but i certainly agree that we are reaching a
point we are on path to reach a point where people
will say we've had enough you know whether it's
with inflation reaching ridiculous highs people
suddenly waking up to see their money losing value
um you know we're talking about food shortages
now we're talking about i don't know about um in
america but in the uk we're not talking about um
gas prices and being a very cold winter and not
being able to afford heating and things like that
i mean okay it feels like we are on this there's
a weird path um but on a on a brighter note
what you do a lot of other things i know that you
do poems you mentioned poems they talked about the
poems you accept bitcoin for them um that's really
interesting i'd love to hear more about that oh
eth actually um oh i thought it was bitcoin uh
i mean i do accept uh bitcoin for poems okay so
there's there's two different poem things um one
of which is just like i literally write you a poem
a custom or um from my repertoire if someone has a
particular theme and and then that just like like
it's like an email for bitcoin it's super simple
um some people prefer nfts as the format uh so
i've made a few poetry nfts in which i mean just
like through wearable or openc people buy the nfts
um i'd say probably like i usually collaborate
with an artist on that to make the visual for it
and i think it's like six or seven that i've
sold so far really not too many and it was
actually before nfts blew up this year so
i the amount of money i made uh selling nft
poems bought my family dinner like it was not it
was not a huge amount of money that's pretty cool
no that is so cool i mean even if you just think
about that but that's still insane you know you
made something you sold it and it it's it's a
poem i think that's really really cool so i mean
most people i think they go into journalism
particularly if you're writing you like to
write so i've been writing poetry since i was
like a child um and it all started i guess in
the crypto space when i made a small poetry chat
book and i sold it uh using a lightning node so i
would send people an invoice they would pay the
note and i physically shipped that book to them
i very quickly realized there was more demand
for that than it made economic sense to in terms
of shipping and printing printing is expensive
paper so that's when i started doing like emails
and nfts and other ways to distribute it because
most of my buyers actually were international so
like international shipping on a book is a
pain but an email or an nft is pretty easy
um so yeah i feel really blessed and lucky about
that because it's not common for people to be able
to actually make money using poetry you know
exactly so i've been very lucky that you know
buyers around the world who are interested in my
words um have been able to give me and sometimes
custom orders are really interesting um really
the weirdest order you've had oh so the weirdest
order i had oh okay so two i guess one of which
was this guy gave me his favorite video game
and wanted me to write about smart contracts using
the characters from this video game as a poem
demanding right right enjoy that challenge um and
another one was there's a guy who really likes
um a particular opera that's like an obscure
swiss opera and he just can't get enough fanfic
about it he was like write me a poem about one
of the characters from this opera so i had to
like research the opera and the character and
like he also wanted me to do it in the style of
sufi poetry so like um ancient iranian poetry
um so yeah in this particular style about this
particular character i never met it was such
an interesting challenge and i really enjoyed
the outcome that is so interesting i wouldn't know
where to start that's why i charge bitcoin because
it is hard there you go yeah no i don't blame
you it sounds pretty difficult but other than
poems and nfts what else are you working on i
know you're freelancing for several different
companies right yeah i'm freelancing and i also am
starting my own magazine it's called defeme it's
actually like a print product we're going to be
distributed in canada in the u.s and also people
can order online and like it came from the idea of
someone came up to me and was like lee what would
happen if you were to make a tech magazine that
was particularly for women it doesn't mean that
everything we talk about it like has to be women
but i think about like you know the colors you're
choosing the topics you're choosing the products
that you're you know having is advertising
usually when you're writing tech media you're
writing for like uh 20 to 40 urban males like
that's just like the target audience you're gonna
make the most money from so like what if you were
just to like not and make it for a different
audience what kind of product would you make and
i'm very grateful and absolutely thrilled so far
we've had over 400 contributors people who gave
either money or articles or art um and together
we're like as a community making this magazine
and it's just such an interesting experiment so
what stage are you at with the magazine uh right
now we are in the stage of going to production
so we've got a printer we are designing and put
together all the stuff that we have collected um
we're having twitter spaces events and other kinds
of online events for people that contributed to
kind of get together and meet each other and talk
um and yeah we're hoping to be out by later this
year and it's so crazy to say that because like
it's actually really hard to uh print and
distribute uh like media um there's like a
few monopolies i don't know about the uk in the
us there's like four-ish companies that control
all the distribution so like if any bookstore you
go into any time you go into a grocery store and
you see something on the shelf like all of that is
owned by like four companies and they can charge
whatever they want in order to get that shelf
space so just like you know the internet opened
up the ability to broadcast to everybody but then
everyone gets bombarded with the slush and print
media you just uh it's very hard to get your foot
in the door and especially you're telling someone
you want to make a magazine that's crypto friendly
they're like what is that and why do we care um
so it's been so it's something wait so
it's something people can subscribe to
and then they can have it delivered to
their door basically yeah yeah as well
okay cool so physical and email uh physical and
there's an online component so we will have some
of the content online but some of it will only
be in print so that's kind of like a collectible
like a pokemon card or an nft like there are only
so many that we're going to print of every issue
and so like when you get that you get you get
the content although some of it obviously will
have like you know twitter spaces with one
of the entrepreneurs who wrote an article
or like you know an interview on the on a
newsletter like a free online newsletter with
someone who contributed this so like we will have
some of it like corresponding to online content
but the print thing itself we're deliberately
not doing as like an online media outlet we're
deliberately doing it that like this is small
community driven and exclusive and collectible
it sounds amazing i think it's really
cool major congrats i'm so excited for
everything to come together for you um but in
terms of you what is your general goal um you
know there's a lot of different things going on
here you know you have the traditional media you
probably never thought you'd end up in crypto now
now you've got the magazine so what is your goal
what is my goal um yeah i want to make a living
and not feel shitty about what i do to do it
that is the goal as someone who worked in
journalism i did not always feel great about
what i was doing sometimes i felt really great
about what i was doing my goal is to be able to
continue to use my skills and it doesn't only mean
media that can also be you know educational and
or organizational but in a way that i feel like
is good for people and i find that's a lot easier
to do independently than it is on staff although
not impossible on stuff and that will mean working
with a variety of different kinds of organizations
um and that that's the goal i'd love just to know
before um before we say bye i'd love to know what
was it that happened in traditional media that you
thought oh god i feel awful reporting on this
oh my god i worked on it for like seven years
so a lot a lot of things like like what like what
really made you just go i can't do this anymore
to be fair there was nothing that made me
do that i don't feel like it's you know
i don't know dealing heroin to babies or
something like it's not like it's something
that's inherently bad you have opportunities to
be good and you have opportunity to do bad but
the thing is like the opportunity to do good is
so uh disproportionate sometimes right like i mean
it's a million little things like uh one benign
example is i wrote an article about uh two women
filmmakers uh it was so pg it was so like these
two women made a movie like nothing controversial
so of course uh the editor puts a a spicy headline
and a picture of two girls in bikinis making out
as the header photo so i go out and i go up to him
and i'm like why the hell would you do this this
has nothing to do with what the article is about
and he was like overruled and it's like a million
wait wait he didn't even give you an explanation
he just said overruled yeah he was just like
my call and it's a million little things like
that every day five days a week seven years
that you just start to think like i want to
have more control over what i'm putting out
into the world because his name is never going
to appear on that and mine does and the people
who send hate mail on the people it's not
even about hamilton you know it's about like
the people who are in the article who come
up to me they're like what happened here lee
and i can't say anything um that's not always
the case i'm extremely lucky that some of the
articles i've gotten to work on with mainstream
outlets i feel like did had a positive impact
on readers i think the high quality job i
really benefited from the editorial leadership
you know there's a lot of times it does work out
well but i think being independent gives me the
ability to choose which editors treat me that
way and to choose to not work again with people
who don't uh have that same ethical standard i
understand it's so it's so weird when you become
um so awake to all the different biases that are
in the media and what the um what their purpose is
and what their priority is um so yeah no i really
appreciate you sharing that it's been really
interesting to hear your perspective obviously
because you know you've spent so much time working
in that traditional world and you still sort of do
at times so yeah that's been really great so lee i
want to thank you so much for coming on it's been
brilliant thank you so much thanks for having me
and oh one last thing do you have any last words
where can people find you where can people follow
you yeah so i will post here in the comments
i don't know if i can post in the comments
can i i don't think i can no i'll put it in
the chat and then i will just read it so uh
following the new magazine i'm working on on
twitter that's defeme so d-e-s-f-e-m-m-e-s-mag
uh defendmag that's uh on twitter if you can
follow me and i'm also in the comments oh perfect
thank you thank you very much and in general i'm
pretty googlable my name is spelled funky so like
if you look for my substance it's my name
you know if you look for me on twitter
my name will help you bring it up pretty much
anything you're looking for in terms of my work
i'm pretty easy to find perfect lee thank
you so much and guys thank you so much
for watching we'll be back next week with
another amazing guest we'll see you then